[Music]
professional wrestling in its most basic
form is a morality play you want to show
case good versus evil I've become
accustomed to being a ladies man bad guy
everywhere I go in the world I come out
I'm quite you know cocky arrogant more
of a villain I don't really care for the
fans I really care about myself but here
in Mexico I've taken it in a different
direction
since the presidential elections I've
been pretty much an avid Donald Trump
supporter as far as the character goes
[Music]
sampling ski dreams of becoming the best
wrestler in the world he's fightin in
Mexico City as a villain he's a tall
blond American a Donald Trump supporter
by the name of Sam Adonis
playing the role of a bad guy here it's
paying off
reaction the Mexican people is just
overwhelming in my history of pro
wrestling nine years and the years as a
fan before that I've never experienced
anything quite like it it's very rare in
this day and age to invoke such genuine
hatred and emotion and professional
wrestling generally people appreciate
the fact that is a show and they go and
they enjoy it they cheer they boo and
they go home with this particular case
we were a little bit more involved in
that they can't really control their
emotions they see it in there they're
offended and they don't know how to
react people here have heard President
Trump calling Mexicans rapists drug
dealers and bad hombres they know that
Trump wants to build a wall between
Mexico and the US and have Mexicans pay
for it
these people have more than a few
reasons to hate President Trump that Sam
didn't just move to reap the benefits
from that sentiment or strum he came to
improve his wrestling skills I've been a
big fan of Mexican Lucha Libre for my
whole life the style is completely
different than the rest of the world
it's chaos it's fun it's a lot like the
circus it's just completely different to
everything you know about professional
wrestling and I aspire to be one of the
best wrestlers on earth and because of
that you need to learn every style you
need to learn the British style you need
to learn the Mexican style and the other
style so for that it's just another stop
on my voyage
and in Mexico Sam has found a community
that he cares for and supports I
absolutely love it here I have had so
much fun with the Mexican people I've
learned a lot about the Mexican people
in the culture in general I have a lot
of respect for the fact that they're so
into family they're so proud of their
culture there so we're proud of being
Mexican to me they want to share Mexico
with you that's just whole city is like
a carnival they've just street vendors
and just things for sale crafts there's
music playing in the streets insane you
love it some Antonis is not an average
Trump supporter outside the ring but he
does have respect for the president one
of the main things I like about Donald
Trump is I he embraces the fact that
bigger is better
he's one of the first politicians to
turn his campaign almost into a rock and
roll tour I feel like he's almost
developed a character who he is based on
a professional wrestling persona he
stays you know in one straight line and
if you don't like it that's your problem
and that's one of the things I admire
most about the guy that's fundamentally
some is not here to do politics he's
here to wrestle I'm just such a purist
for wrestling I love pro wrestling I
think
I think it's the best art form on earth
I think you know if people understood it
they were just
[Music]
you